So there's lots of different ways you could have solved
this. You need to use the print command to print out
the result. And then we want an expression that calculates the
number of minutes in seven weeks. There's seven weeks, each week
has seven days, so we can have seven times seven for
the number of days. Then to get the number of minutes,
we need to multiply that by 24 to get the number
of hours And then multiply again, by 60. That should give
us the number of minutes. So let's see that in the Python interpreter. And now
we hit Run, and we see that we have 70,560 minutes. Seems
like a lot of time. It's going to go pretty quick, and we hope by
the end of the seven weeks, all of you will be accomplished Python programmers.